come molti vocaboli e scientifica la
resilienza un origine latina il verbo
resi lira viene dalla giunta del
professore al verbo salire saltare
zampillare quindi e quindi dando
immediatamente il significato di tornare
indietro di colpo rimbalzare restituendo
il senso di un'esperienza quotidiana vi
dico quindi subito che nel mondo in cui
entriamo adesso l'esperienza quotidiana
del nostro mondo newtoniano dove le mele
ci cadono sulla testa
il tempo passa nello stesso modo per
tutti e gemelli avranno sempre la stessa
età non ci servirà molto
entriamo nel mondo dell'infinitamente
grande in cui le cose vanno diversamente
e la relatività generale scoperta
l'estragolo scorso ci insegna che la
natura è ben più sottile di 4chan paia
quindi cominciamo il nostro viaggio
devo applicare il termine resilience
all'universo non è banale ho dovuto
cercare abbiamo visto anche delle di
cisse di nicole di nicola sono spesso
legati ai materiali sono legati alle
persone all'ecologia ho dovuto cercare
quindi un semplicissimo filo rosso da
poter seguire
vedremo se ci porta fino alla fine ma
l'idea è molto semplice
questo universo che ci accoglie
resilient quale qual è il nostro destino
e cominciamo allora innanzitutto
il fatto che come probabilmente sapete
la luce impiega del tempo a viaggiare e
quindi non è istantaneo il passaggio
della luce da un oggetto ai nostri occhi
si nun ci attribuisce immediatamente dei
superpoteri
quando vediamo il sole quella luce che
vediamo ci ha messo otto minuti a fare
150 milioni di chilometri che c'è tra
noi e la nostra stella quando guardiamo
il cielo una notte stellata
vediamo un citato antico un cielo che
magari non c'è neanche più così stelle
che non ci sono più quindi dobbiamo
capire che guardare indietro nello
spazio significa anche guardare nel
tempo
quella che vedete qui è una fotografia
straordinaria quelle non sono stelle
quelle sono galassie in questa
fotografia ci sono tra le galassie più
antiche che siano mai esistite tra le
prime galassie dell'universo
praticamente universo cia circa 13,8
miliardi di anni
alcuni di quei puntini sullo sfondo
hanno solo 800 milioni di anni
stiamo guardando indietro stiamo
guardando quasi all'inizio della storia
dell'universo quindi per poter fare
questa fotografia al telescopio diavolo
ha dovuto per 11 giorni restare fisso in
una posizione
per ricevere tutti questi fotoni questi
granelli di luce che
hanno cominciato un viaggio 13 miliardi
di anni fa per arrivare al suo obiettivo
quindi vediamo che all'inizio le prime
galassie già le galassie più adulte
hanno delle forme più riconoscibili le
spirali le galassie ellittiche e poi ne
parleremo
ma la questione è se possiamo guardare
indietro nel tempo possiamo un giorno
non so magari con un telescopio
potentissimo arrivare a vedere il big
bang
la risposta è no a questa risposta per
noi è importante nel nostro filo della
resilience la risposta è no perché il
big ben comincia con una grande palla
incandescente un plasma di a temperature
vulcaniche enormi che piano piano si
espande e si raffredda solo dopo 380.000
anni la luce e la materia si dividono
cominciano un viaggio separato sono
quegli stessi fotoni lì quindi una luce
imperturbabile una luce che avanza che
permea l'universo che sembra uguale
dappertutto una luce potremmo dire
resiliente soprattutto se vediamo cosa è
successo nel frattempo alla materia che
invece ha avuto un percorso ben più
violento allora la materia universo
atomi idrogeno questa è una prima
fotografia una tante baby stelle che
stanno per nascere
quindi questi eventi in cui gas idrogeno
sotto la pressione della gravità
collassano e innescano una fusione
nucleare creando le stelle che le
faranno brillare per milioni miliardi di
anni
un aneddoto giove
il più grande pianeta del sistema solare
per pochissimo non riuscito a diventare
una stella non è riuscito a far partire
la fusione nucleare e dobbiamo dire
anche per fortuna non sarebbe stato
facile vivere con un sistema solare ha
due soli di cui con oltre tutto così
vicino
quindi le stelle nascono le stelle
muoiono
questa è una delle mie foto preferita
spero che renda con la luce
possiamo anche abbassare le luci che si
può questo è il quello che resta
dell'esplosione di una supernova
avvenuta nel 1600 le stelle possono
morire in tanti modi il nostro sole
quando morirà tra quattro miliardi di
anni diventerà una gigante rossa
inizialmente non avrà più combustibile
si mangerà mercurio e venere e piano
piano comincerà a diventare sempre più
densa diventerà una nana bianca bianca
densissima un cucchiaino di non è bianca
sono 100 tonnellate e sparirà le stelle
più grandi invece hanno una fine diversa
molto più violenta
per esempio le esplosioni di supernove
che costellano sono acqua sono tra gli
eventi più pirotecnici più colorati che
possiamo vedere l'universo queste
meravigliosa è una bolla appunto che si
espande a 18 milioni di chilometri l'ora
e sa qualcosa di celestiale di mistico
io la amo particolarmente
dietro quelle che vedete sono stelle
ecco qui una galassia una delle coppie
degli astrofisici perché in realtà ci
sta ben di fronte si vede bene è solo
per darvi un'idea purtroppo solo 18
minuti quindi faremo una foto e devo
seguire il senso della resilience quindi
una galassia a spirale come la nostra
due terzi delle galassie dell'universo
no questa forma tra cui appunto
via lattea vediamo che interagisce con
una piccola galassia accanto e tutti
questi puntini rossi sono fabbriche di
stelle sono stelle che stanno lasciando
quindi un'attività estremamente ricca
appunto un fenomeni che producono
energia colorati noi ripeto la nostra
galassia
non ve la farò vedere mai più o meno
così e viene anche di buchi neri ne
parleremo dopo la nostra galassia per
esempio al suo centro nostra galasso ci
sono milioni che forse anche di più di
buchi neri in particolare 1 pesantissimo
il sagittario a che pesa 4 milioni di
soli e che al centro della nostra classe
ne abbiamo anche uno non lontano ma non
ci sono pericoli
quindi anche qui grandi attività
questa è cassiopea è un altro residuo di
una una delle esplosioni di supernova
più recenti una delle più giovani di
supernove esplose ecco questo è un video
che riproduce l'esplosione di cassiopea
la bellezza di questo video mi permette
di dire una cosa che anche molto
importante nella percezione che abbiamo
del nostro universo
e c'è questa esplosione muta non perché
non c'è l'audio ma perché l'universo
moto nell'universo non c'è suono il
suono per la musica il suono sono
privilegio della terra è di tutti i
corpi dove c'è un'atmosfera per potersi
propagare ha bisogno di qualcosa da
muovere come se buttiamo il sasso in uno
stagno
se non c'è acqua non ci sono onde che
arrivano sulla riva quindi tutti questi
tutti questi fenomeni
ripeto violenti le esplosioni
vedremo le galassie che si mangiano
avvengono in un silenzio assoluto e
in qualche modo almeno questa è la mia
opinione sottrae la violenza all'evento
fondo la violenza passa anche dal suono
quindi prima rimangono soprattutto ci
sono immagini meravigliose
continuiamo a vedere altre galassie
per esempio questo qui è un quintetto in
realtà un quintetto di galassie vicino
in realtà questo acquisto è molto più
vicino a noi e anche qui vediamo le
galassie che stanno insieme considerate
che la maggior parte dei grandi galassie
sono cannibali se ne sono mangiate altre
per diventare quello che sono
soprattutto le galassie a forma di
sigaro le liti che se ne sono mangiate
parecchie nel loro percorso quindi ecco
qui un altro elemento di non resilience
un altro elemento di violenza di
trasformazioni che non tornano indietro
questo è particolarmente bella anche
questa è una delle delle ultime foto in
realtà è misleading non c'è veramente
correlazione tra le due e sono quattro
galassia però l'ho messa perché è molto
bella
allora questo queste sono si chiamano i
mais i topolini sono due classi che
stanno per fondersi sono due galassie
che stanno per diventare una ovviamente
fra centinaia di milioni di anni la
nostra galassia
allora li abbiamo quando osserviamo le
galassie intorno a noi vediamo che si
con l'universo si espande scappano
fuggono e si spostano nel rosso ciano
una luce rossa il rosso vuol dire stop
sto allontanandovi date quando guardiamo
andromeda che invece è una glassa più
vicino a noi
andromeda c'è una luce nel blu quindi
tra virgolette ci sta venendo addosso
infatti andromeda ci sta venendo addosso
cc prenderà tra circa 44 miliardi di
anni oltretutto andromeda è un
conducente
comunque spericolato se n'è già mangiate
sono già mangiate almeno un'altra di
galassie venendo verso di noi e appunto
si avvicina una velocità di circa 112
chilometri al secondo ma l'impatto
avverrà solo fra quattro miliardi di
anni
questa è una simulazione non c'è da
preoccuparsi perché nel frattempo il
nostro sole anche si sarà spento quindi
diciamo non dovremmo arrivare fino a
questo quando vedo questa foto penso
sempre una battuta di woody allen dice
ma allora se finisce così l'ho pagata
davvero troppo la moquette infatti c'è
proprio il senso della catastrofe
allora abbiamo visto la luce
imperturbabile la materia non sembra
assolutamente restano vorrei fermare il
video se veniamo son sempre un attimo
quindi un universo che non sembra almeno
per quanto sia il suo contenuto così
resilient comunque un universo colorato
e un universo stupefacente
non ho parlato di buchi neri ma i buchi
neri sono caldi evaporano sono quanto di
meno resilient anche nel nostro
immaginario buco nero possa essere
questa materia che scivola in un buco
dello spazio tempo persino la lucha non
riesce a sfuggire la ma non basta
osservare se vogliamo rispondere alla
domanda iniziale che ne sarà di questo
universo non ci basta osservare quello
che abbiamo visto non ci dice molto
abbiamo bisogno di capire quali sono i
meccanismi dietro questo universo cioè
come come funziona e soprattutto di
quante cose è fatto allora per parlare
di questo
quest'anno passiamo a questa foto
davvero diciamo un turning point nella
nostra comprensione del mondo sono
quest'anno 100 anni delle equazioni di
einstein
allora einstein nel 1915 stava finendo
la sua relatività generale che è un
concetto abbastanza diciamo facile da
semplificare fondamentalmente una grossa
concentrazione di massa modifica in
curva lo spazio e il tempo come una
grossa palla messa su un tappeto
elastico su un materasso o su una rete
metallica quindi lo spazio si incurva si
flette è ondulato e questo significa che
il tempo anche in presenza di una massa
scorre si si si stira quindi scorre più
lentamente i diciotto minuti del ted
bari sono mi permetto di dire due parole
in più di 18 minuti del tub dead cortina
per esempio cosa succede ai stesso
scrivendo le sue le sue equazioni in
quel periodo c'era una fede assoluta in
un universo stazionario e cioè un
universo che non si muove vista scrive
le sue equazioni gli viene fuori un
universo in espansione
impossibile non è possibile non può
essere in espansione aggiunge un termine
artificialmente la costante cosmologica
e lo ferma una specie di energia che lo
che fermava l'espansione contento
nascerà generale nel 29 l'astronomo
hubble 19 l'universo si espande le
galassie si allontanano l'una dall'altra
la matematica aveva avuto ragione
einstein aveva ragione quindi abbiamo un
momento decisivo nella nostra
comprensione dell'universo le sue
equazioni di campo semplicissime ci
permettevano già di descrivere
l'universo come lo osservavano alle
varie dimensioni
ma cosa c'è nell'universo
come facciamo a dire se resi lento no
quello che noi osserviamo e che emette
radiazione luce quindi atomi le polveri
pianeti le stelle eccetera
conta solo per il 4 per cento di quello
che c'è nell'universo il resto un 22 per
cento e materia oscura degli aloni
intorno le galassie
ma il resto il 70 per cento che cos'è
soprattutto perché abbiamo scoperto da
poco che l'universo sta la sua
espansione sta accellerando com'è
possibile che gli dà la forza di
accelerare oggi si pensa che questo 70
per cento sia un'energia dentro lo
spazio tempo proprio descritta da quella
costante cosmologica che einstein aveva
messo lì per altri motivi
quindi ci ritroviamo in una situazione
in cui questo universo
ci tengo diciamo proprio per riprendere
il filo questo universo che appunto e
colorate buchi neri evaporano le stelle
si mangiano si tirano si trasformano e
dove in mezzo interstellare vibra con la
superficie del mare non sembra d'esilio
ma ma abbiamo visto che ci sono queste
equazioni non le ho messe perché vi ho
già spaventato troppo ma in realtà erano
abbastanza l'equazione molto piccolo e
sintetica queste equazioni ci descrivono
sono ci danno delle leggi universali
semplici descrivono questa trama sottile
della matematica del nostro universo che
ci permette anche di prevedere di
anticipare ora messo questa perché
quel robottino lille abbiamo fatto
arrivare noi su una cometa meno di un
anno fa e quindi ci tenevo a farlo
vedere
e voglio anche tornare sulla terra un
attimo perché parlavamo della cina
allora qual è la nostra speranza di
residenza è in queste leggi di natura
universali semplici siamo partiti della
domanda perché c'è qualcosa piuttosto
che niente
la risposta è perché sì perché se non ci
fosse questo qualcosa non ci noi non ci
potremmo porre questa domanda e quindi
l'essenza di ogni curiosità di ogni
domanda el esserci quindi il il in
queste leggi nella loro struttura la
nostra la nostra resilience è anche la
nostra speranza di conoscenza la parola
desiderio viene da desidero un s essere
lontani dalle stelle
penso che sia dentro ognuno di noi
questo anelito di ricongiungerci con le
stelle e e di capire grazie